si les agriculteurs normands se disent
inquiets les habitants lyonnais ne tente
d'égayer leur vie de confiner reportage
dans le 7e arrondissement de la capitale
des gaules signé luis carballo et la
médiane
bonsoir à tout la douce
bienvenue à la deuxième grille et public
de continent ne sont toujours les oil
berne est troisième chaque soir à 19
heures sauf le dimanche valérie ya alex
et ça donne de la voix pour délivrer les
messages de leurs voisins dans cette
copropriété de quelque 350 habitants il
m'a perdre deux jours à voir j'espère
que nous pourrons en parler en classe
verte une aventure entre ses amis qui a
commencé le 19 mars dernier 48 heures
après le début du confinement
on s'est dit qu'on allait aider les gens
de notre immeuble
au départ on pensait peut-être aller
toquer aux portes pour faire des coupes
pour les personnes âgées ou les
personnes fragiles par exemple et
finalement on a discuté et on se dit
tiens crier ça pourrait être une super
idée pour les voisins et du coup on a
fait des affiches on les a posées
dans la cour tout autour elles y sont
encore d'ailleurs et on a mis une
adresse mail un numéro de téléphone et
le lendemain on avait sept messages
un anniversaire en voisin la recherche
de bdm de vis voir un message d'amour
les trois amis sont là pour transmettre
les écrits à haute voix l'accueil est
très bon alors c'est possible qu'ils
aient des voisins qui
qui n'a pas envie de nous écouter pour
le coup ils se font discrets et ils sont
pas trop méchant avec nous donc ça va et
le public répond présent depuis les
fenêtres ou la pelouse de la copropriété
ils le font très bien c'est tout le
monde est content j'applaudis et je
devais je t'ai l'itie pour cette belle
initiative et je demande qu'une chose
c'est que ça se reproduise évoqué qu'il
continue à nous à nous émerveiller
un spectacle qui évolue au jour le jour
ce soir là une voisine s'improvise
cantatrice et en russe il vous plait
[Musique]
le voyage musical continue avec
maintenant l'ecosse à l'honneur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
les moments de partage en cette période
d'isolement qui resteront gravés à
jamais chez les petits et chez les
grands
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]